Tyger Tyger hey buddy where are you
tiger tiger hey tiger have you seen the
cat ah tiger buddy how did we lose him
the first day okay I checked the door so
there's no way he got out no no no no no
tiger what do we do what do we do what
do we do what do we do what do we do
what do we do we can't go to jail for
losing a cat right uh no I hope coyotes
didn't get him all right it's fine
hi buster hello
yeah we're not getting a cat okay I mean
we could have a baby instead we're
supposed to introduce one room at a time
so he doesn't get overwhelmed
all right he's out and about oh look at
him go
gave me life I guess maybe we should say
ground rule no cat on the furniture yeah
no cat on furniture oh well Oh already
just say no scratching maybe he only
scratches the scratching post so that
well oh okay
I don't want fur on my clothes yeah no
clothes right he's in the lawn yeah okay
ah you know what this is his first day
it's a free day yeah okay maybe just no
cat in the vicinity of wood that's good
oh no no hold on hold on do you think we
should give him your last name or my
last name we go with my last name
why isn't so yeah that sounds like an
auditor I think it's very regal it's
like command something like that little
tiger
oh I like tiger how about tiger I like
tiger you like tiger mmm
that's the claws coming out he's been
sleeping a lot I mean what if it hasn't
been sleeping enough I'm gonna call it
oh no no no
what's happening do you think this
plants poisonous uh the ficus I know is
this ficus is ficus poisonous ah that's
a ficus so we have Appetit so correct
your best guess p'tee so festive
hey welcome cats even each Vitesse 'as
the tea side
I'm calling the vet all of it you're a
hard sell I understand that you command
only the best entertainment oh did you
baby
where did Paul go who is this new guy
well he's pretty fun not as fun as old
tall old Paul's back come on tiger come
on down I don't even understand how it
got up there he not it maybe we should
just leave this cat alone oh oh oh oh
now we're having fun
Donaire oh the good old [ __ ] sir top
scenario good how are you eating right
now eating here tiger you hungry he's
coming down he's coming down and now we
know how to make him do stuff so today
was insane yeah I think he'd love that
you think mm-hmm yeah I think he does
you're my little guy cuz we're a family
now
you and me and Paul we're gonna get
married we're gonna have a baby
you